- We are back.
And you have seen it
happen from time to time
here on this show, I get
to talking with guests
and the conversations go along
'cause mama likes to talk.
That's why we keep a vault of interviews
we couldn't fit in the original show,
but we wanna make sure
that you don't miss.
Today's Kelly Extra takes
us back to September
when we had Scarlett Johansson here.
We got to talking about our kids
and one of the cardinal
Marvel Universe rules
she said she would never break.
Check it out.
When Jeremy Renner was here,
he was talking about he
used his Hawkeye costume
for Halloween.
Have you ever done that?
- What?
- You've never done that?
- That is--
- I would totally do that.
- That's allowed?
Marvel never told me I could do that.
- I don't.
I feel like Jeremy maybe says sorry,
doesn't ask permission.
Maybe he's one of those people.
- You're actually right.
That's definitely.
- I'm one of those people.
So yeah, 'cause then you
can always say sorry later.
I would totally do it.
- I'm not, I am very by
the books, like I don't,
I am the person that is, I don't wanna be
I'm constantly like, I worked
for Marvel for 10 years
and I was constantly
terrified I was gonna spoil
some major, yeah, like anything from like,
the color of my, that it's like
now a darker shade of navy,
it was like, you can't say a thing.
- Oh wow.
- I'm sort of programmed to, yeah.
- Sounds a little abusive, but yeah.
(Kelly laughs)
Programmed.
- What do you mean?
- Yeah.
I would, I don't do well with
secrets or anything like that
so I would hate that
having to keep a secret.
I don't, no.
- There is definitely cast
members that, Mark Ruffalo, yeah,
that are really, really bad at it,
that are like a liability.
- I call it passion.
We're just excited about something.
So that's why we give it away on accident.